lionel labarre ans président du syndicat
les biologistes médicaux bonsoir les
navarro merci d'être avec nous et je
précise que vous êtes actuellement à
strasbourg vous travaillez donc le grand
test qui avait son souvient
malheureusement été l'épicentre de
l'épidémie au début il y a deux ans
aujourd'hui un chaos mikron étaient
détectés en alsace à colmar et surtout
les centre hospitalier de mulhouse et de
colmar ainsi que de strasbourg ont
déclenché le plan blanc est ce que c'est
la crainte des vieux fantômes qui se
réveille où les choses sont tout de même
bien différente aujourd'hui
alors les choses sont différentes dans
le sens où on peut mieux tester et pour
l'instant on a moins de personnes qui
sont hospitalisées
on n'a qu'à une petite expérience sur la
crise on m'a plus de personnes qui
attrape le virus sans se retrouver
nécessairement à l'hôpital mme en
réanimation lorsqu'ils sont vaccinés en
revanche bien sûr c'est un flou pour
nous parce que ce variant comme les
autres on ne le connaît pas bien on sait
pas si les plus graves si les plus
contagieuses si les plus résistants à la
vaccination ne manque encore beaucoup de
données pour savoir ce que ça va donner
et en plus il peut y avoir d'autres
variantes qui circulent qu'on ne connaît
pas encore d'où l'importance en france
de développer le séquençage non
seulement aux détecter le coronavirus
mais aussi voir s'il ya de nouvelles
mutations qui peuvent avoir un intérêt
médical on sait qu on a souvent invité
infinie programme que vous devez
forcément connaître c'est une sommité
dans ce domaine notamment
le séquençage c'est quelque chose qui
fait extrêmement défaut en france
manifestement est ce qu on a fait
quelques progrès depuis le début de la
pandémie
alors oui on a fait quelques progrès et
on a beaucoup poussé pour que les
laboratoires qui ont une capacité une
compétence en séquençage puisse être
appelé à la mobilisation notamment les
laboratoires privés aux côtés des
laboratoires publics mais actuellement
on a plus de capacités et ses
laboratoires là n'ont pas encore été
appelé et nous on pousse depuis le début
pour que l'ensemble des capacités en
séquençage soit utilisée en france et
notamment qu'on ait des résultats plus
rapides parce qu'à l'heure actuelle on a
beaucoup de temps entre le moment où on
envoie un résultat séquençage jusqu'au
moment où on à l'interprétation
expliquez-nous comment ça se passe ce
séquençage
vous êtes dans un laboratoire vous êtes
obligé de l'envoyer dans une forme de
laboratoire qui fait centre qui
pratiquent ce séquençage pour déterminer
quelle variante c'est bien cela
voilà exactement et on a deux deux types
de séquençage de différent dans le sens
où on en voit d'un côté du séquençage
aléatoire c'est à dire tous les lundis
par exemple tous les échantillons
positifs sont envoyées donc là c'est la
pêche à la ligne et on a aussi du
séquençage ciblé ciblées notamment
lorsqu'on a une pcr suspecte
c'est-à-dire un criblage qui ne colle
pas avec le variant delta ce moment là
ce prélèvement là on va le sait quand
c'est parce que c'est pas du variant
delta donc on veut savoir ce que c'est
ou par exemple quand quelqu'un revient
d'un pays à risque et qu'il a une
épaisseur positif ce prélèvement là on
va aussi le séquencé puisque c'est plus
suspecte de variants au micro voilà il
ya aussi un séquençage spécifiques et
ciblées qui est fait mais encore une
fois on manque de séquençage en france
et ça prend un peu trop de temps pour
avoir les résultats pour l'instant alors
ça veut dire quoi de conséquence
peut-être à cela on sous estime peut
être le nombre de ce nouveau variant par
exemple et peut-être aussi le risque
d'avoir un délai
pour justement connaître le chiffre
exact
alors oui bien sûr le nombre de dons
micron présents sur le territoire est
sous-estimé c'est clair maintenant
encore une fois surtout on voudrait
savoir qu'est ce que c'est que ce
variant là et en quoi ça va changer la
politique nationale on l'a vu avec le
variant delta l'isolément est passé de 7
jours à 10 jours est ce que on va avoir
une politique différente avec ce variant
micron pour l'instant on ne le sait pas
est ce qu'il va falloir changer les
vaccinations les adapter pour l'instant
on ne le sait pas pour l'instant ce
qu'on sait c'est une chose c'est que le
mieux c'est de miser sur la stratégie
tester alerté protégées dont dès qu'on a
des symptômes tout testé pour isoler la
personne éventuellement tester d'autres
virus que le colis pia pas que l'aco
vide en france et c'est bien de savoir
qui est qui et nous ont tous là
également pour pouvoir détecter qu'ovide
mais également de riz et vrs ça c'est
des choses qu'on pensait il ya autre
chose qui peut aider bien sûr c'est les
gestes barrières on sait malheureusement
même avec la vaccination
surtout quand elle est ancienne on peut
quand même attrapé le virus et le
diffuser à notre entourage donc il faut
toujours rester vigilant et évidemment
le troisième volet c'est la vaccination
pour l'instant ça fonctionne sur les
variants actuelle probablement également
en partie sur au micron donc misant sur
la vaccination parce que si les hôpitaux
sont débordés avec le variant delta je
ne sais pas bien on rame est très malade
dans une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines parce que nous en laboratoire
on voit une explosion du nombre de cas
positifs et on aimerait que ces
personnes-là n'aillent pas se retrouver
à l'hôpital dans une semaine ou deux
semaines et on voit bien que les
personnes vaccinées avec une troisième
dose ont moins de risque d'être en
réanimation que les autres donc voilà il
ya trois volets c'est des choses simples
mais on a que ça pour l'instant tant
qu'on sait pas ce que c'est au micro on
n'a que ça justement lui même marrant
c'était évidemment la question suivante
vous dans les laboratoires vous venez de
me le dire vous voyez qu'il ya une forme
de deux rues est ce qu'on est niveau
comparable à la première vague à la
deuxième vague bref où c'est à peu près
finalement similaire ou peut-être moins
important
alors honnêtement les équipes sont
extrêmement chargé peut-être un tout
petit peu moins quand on est non grande
de l'année dernière mais même pas
franchement qu'on doit être à un niveau
à peu près similaire avec un taux de
positivité supérieure à 10% en tout cas
dans ma région ce qui est extrêmement
élevé ça fait partie des plus hauts on a
un peu moins de personnes hospitalisées
et en réalise qu'on avait à l'époque
heureusement et ça c'est grâce à la
vaccination mais on a les chiffres qui
monte - quand j'y suis avec mes
collègues de l'hôpital je sens qu'il ya
des tensions qui montent à ce niveau là
donc il faut qu'on soit extrêmement
vigilants tous ensemble et je sais pas
bien si ça continue d'augmenter à cette
vitesse là nous par exemple on a doublé
le nombre de pcr depuis la semaine
dernière donc en une semaine on a fait x
2 si on continue comme ça dans une
semaine ou dans deux semaines on y
arrivera plus parce que là on commence à
toucher doucement les limites de nos
capacités de nouveaux puits forés
vigilant là dessus
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup lionel
barreaux un président du syndicat des
biologistes médicaux de nous avoir
éclairé en direct assure rt france ce
soir